yeah for me the one piece of clothing i
find really hard to rock
is a good suit i don't know i don't know
i don't know what it is about a suit
right um love wearing suits yeah i know
you love wearing suit you you you use
every opportunity you can to just rock
up when you're a joker like
we'll go to the grocery store suit up
shut up
why not suits are so fun to wear man it
is it is really fun
you feel like you commend a presence
when you're wearing a suit you know like
when i when i leave my house around the
jojo suit
like you know like i go on the train i'm
like yeah [ __ ] yeah
i'm wearing this because like for me
like i can rock a suit but it really
needs to be tailor-made because like
anything else if
most like my entire life if i just buy
like this store made suit you know
it feels it just feels like i'm wearing
my dad's clothes
i look like five years younger and i and
that's not a good it's not a good five
years younger
it looks like i'm back to being a
teenager yeah i don't know especially as
well here if you wear
anything other than the standard
businessman suit here which is like what
the navy
like the navy blue white t-shirt
underneath it's like not really navy
it's like dark
navy like they they all wear the same
goddamn suit so when i you know when i
whip out my little like
i don't know burgundy what color is it
like beige it's like the jojo beige suit
it stands out so [ __ ] much
one right yeah and i'm like yeah you you
i'm like yeah [ __ ]
i know it's hot like i forget sometimes
you have you bought two jojo's
because you only wear that one yeah
because because the other one is like
way more formal
so it's a little harder to wear it like
on like just kind of like not super
serious yeah yeah cause i i've got the
other one the the butcherarty one yeah
it's like the the navy blue like kind of
a little more standard looking it's also
like a crossover and i feel like the
crossover is like more mafia more like
super serious whereas the jonno one
because it's just like super chill it's
like bay
beige is not a serious color no people
who wear beige don't do serious things
but you can look good all right explain
serious things
like i don't know you see someone
wearing this suit like people
like mafia members here is the jonno
suit here is the bucharati suit right
the bucharati suit looks like you you
are killing people you're trading in
stocks that can't be bought by public
citizens you know
the jonah one looks like you know like
like you have fun times you got for nice
meals you know
it's a different kind of atmosphere yeah
i go to the girls bar every now and then
it's a different kind of atmosphere that
it gives off right
it's like wearing a three-piece you
can't casually wear a three piece but i
love wearing three i love wearing
you look so [ __ ] good in the three
piece because i don't something
you know i i like how men's fashion no
matter how
how much time has passed right a suit
and a three-piece just always looks good
yeah
that it's just something that is
timeless and i don't know what it is
they've just like
we we optimized how good guys could look
like hundreds of years ago
uh and then it just hasn't changed since
then yeah yeah the standard has always
been the same
i remember i don't really spend much
money on clothes but obviously
suit's quite expensive yeah and anyone
who's bought bought a suit will know
that
like a nice suit yeah like a nice suit
right like yeah you can go to primark
and get the 20
suits or whatever and it doesn't look
bad actually yeah it doesn't yeah i
remember i was telling like i was
talking about on
on twitch i was talking about the jojo
suits because they're bringing out new
jojo suits and i'm like yeah i'm going
to buy them all and they were like the
part four ones right
part four ones yeah and they're like
they're like 500 bucks each and i'm like
listen guys
for a suit 500 bucks is not that much
especially if you can go in there and
get they tailor it a little bit to you
like this come on this these suits are
[ __ ] good especially as an adult as
well like that's just gonna
last yeah bro you think i'm i'm i'm only
ever wearing those
jojo suits now it's a one time thing i'm
never wearing i'm never wearing any
other suits ever
right i'm in a pretty well but you know
i mean i might get my [ __ ] money's
worth right and also they're nice things
they're luxurious man you gotta like you
know
a good suit you can't cheap out if you
go to a job interview wearing a cheap
ass suit
come on yeah come on i mean you go to a
job interview wearing a jojo suit
bro they're like interested in
application presence has been commended
when i you know you walk in right
this boy is serious in his beige
bowling never mind he's got a jojo yeah
he's got a beige suit on he's good
i mean that's the thing about the suit
is that it's one of it's one of the few
things that you really can't cheap out
no you can't you can try i mean like you
know you can go to places like you can
get a pretty
cheap suit in somewhere like thailand
that's like tailor-made and everything
like that but
if you don't have that luxury of buying
of going to a place where it can be made
for cheap then
a cheap suit really shows like almost
like
you feel like damn i'm powerful it comes
off in the aura that you give off
it's like some hunter hunter men stuff
right you're like people can feel your
presence when you
when you're in a good suit people know
you are in a good suit they feel it in
the way that you act
i'm telling you man it's not [ __ ]
that's what i do when i go by soon i'm
just like excuse me is the aura taylor
didn't do it
honestly honestly
you know it's not it's an option though
yeah you know it's too tailor-made when
they're asking questions you're like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
they're like they're asking you stuff
like how would you like this or that i'm
like i've never been asked that question
in my life what is that
done they show you like i don't care
what do you think you're the tailor you
tell me it's like would you like two
centimeters or three centimeters off
your cuff
i don't know yeah like when they ask
like do you want the leg rolled up at
the bottom
yeah i was like i don't know just tell
me what looks good i i literally have no
[ __ ] what do you do
tell me because i remember like the
first time i wore a suit
was for like my high school prom or
something i think that was the first
time that everybody did yeah you get
like the primark
your parents are not buying you a good
suit because you're not going to get any
value out of yeah little [ __ ]
and everyone everyone does look like
they're wearing them right
i think it's impossible it's like the
oversized suits
oh god it looks so unnatural good the
good old days where
you just get away why is it that every
like 16 year old who goes like their
first prom in a suit just looks like
they're just
like cause you're not comfortable yeah
but like it's it's so funny how like
every photo i've ever seen either of
myself or of my friends or
just complete random strangers at their
problems they all look like they're
t-posing
you know what i mean they're like they
all they all look like they're just
standing like yes we are out of prom
the suit is like fifty percent the suit
fifty percent how comfortable you feel
wearing
yeah yeah can you embody what a suit is
you know you can't just put on a suit be
like i guess i'm i guess i'm kind of
like
yeah attractive now no you gotta believe
that when you put that suit on yeah i'm
hot
yeah you're gonna give off that aura
you're gonna have faith but like
okay there's there's always this there's
always like every time i wear a suit
right there's always this countdown of
like
when am i going to take this jacket off
because inevitably when you go to like
any celebrations or something
you're going to get too hot in that yeah
of course of course and i i feel like
you know if you're going to take
pictures or do anything get it right at
the beginning of the night
because there's nothing more messier
than like just the suit that you know
has just been battered
and damaged and like you can tell it's
it's not the suit itself it's the tie
right yeah like at the beginning you're
like you got you're buttoned up
right to the top button your tie is
tight you look [ __ ] suave yeah
five hours in god you're a sweaty mess
that tie
has taken a beating it's like it's like
halfway down your chest